your safety or security or economy or on
the line and 14 days two weeks from
tonight you decide if Nancy Pelosi
speaker Maxine Waters Adam Schiff Jerry
Nadler all chair committees do you want
those people holding the Trump agenda
hostage vote for a Democrat is a vote
for any of the people you see on your
screen that's now RNC chairwoman Ron up
McDaniel is with us and the author of
The New York Times bestseller the deep
state Fox News contributor Jason Chavis
what happens if they win well think
about those people become chairman
chairman you got to refer to Maxine
Waters is the chairman Jerry Nadler
chairing Judiciary Committee and Adam
Schiff will displace Devon Nunez and all
those adventures flyer yeah and all
those investigations do you see Jim
Jordan and Mark Meadows and and
Radcliffe and Gowdy do those go away
because they're gonna dismiss those and
you're gonna give Elijah Cummings and
you're gonna give Jerry Nadler the power
of subpoena to go after this
administration day after day McDaniels I
feel better about the Senate I don't
have a crystal ball than I do about the
house Nate silver says 82% chance
Republicans keep the Senate 86% chance
they lose the house he was wrong in 2016
is he wrong tonight I think he's wrong
Sean I mean listen they've been talking
about this blue wave over and over and
over again
we're not seeing it we're not seeing it
in the early voting in Florida and
Nevada in states that we're already
seeing results come in and certainly on
the Senate side we're seeing leads open
up in North Dakota and Missouri and
Indiana so there's great opportunities
to pick up seats but you are right we
have to get out and vote when you just
talked about what would happen if we
lose the house I know it's not Halloween
yet but a shiver just went down my spine
so we need all of our voters to get out
this is not a done deal the Democrats
are energized and the only way we keep
the house is if we get out and get our
voters out so talk to your family talk
to your friends go to vote GOP comm and
get everyone out to the polls we are
fighting for our future we know what
Nancy Pelosi means higher taxes abolish
ice open borders admiring our country
down in investigation after a fashion to
keep Obamacare that's not that radical
agenda Jason chase know it is think
about they want to raise taxes they want
to abolish ice they want these open
borders they don't announce any of this
violence
they stand for the resistance movement
they want this scorched earth that's
what they they're going to deliver what
they're promising we should believe but
all of these people Rana they're all
they're not telling their agenda they
tell Maxine Maxine shush even John
Podesta
the Center for American Progress now one
Democrat talks about the caravan headed
toward southern border because they want
open borders they support amnesty
sanctuary cities and states so that's
what they really want but they're not
saying it Beretta Singh are caught
calling the people of Tennessee ignorant
we know that McCaskill got caught saying
I'm anti-gun I'm all Pro or what
everything Obama believed Heitkamp staff
saying she'll be a super liberal you
know thank God Project Veritas got this
tape yeah I mean they are the liars you
know it's funny that the mainstream
media says that about our president
who's told the truth and actually
delivered on the promises he made on the
campaign trail but you have Democrat
after Democrat being caught in a lie
running is one thing and then saying
yeah just elect me and then when I get
there all governed with Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi has said
very clearly you have a free pass run
against me say you won't vote for me for
speaker because I know when you come
home you're gonna vote for Nancy Pelosi
which would be a disaster in the house
as a vote for her well first a Senate
Democrat as a vote for Schumer good to
see it Congrats on the book thank you